pete amaral thérèse qu'au bon choix aux
gets à montréal il faut rappeler
pourquoi plus difficile disons cela
comme ça d' exercer son métier de
journaliste à moscou impossible dans les
standards que nous on se donne et avec
la liberté à laquelle on est habitués et
qu'on revendique donc oui on est
suspendue pour quelques temps les
opérations moscou mais on a encore un
bureau et on espère y retourner très
bientôt très bien on a demandé hier au
public de nous avez des questions on a
été submergée beaucoup je remercie les
gens sincèrement et on en a choisi
quelques-unes je vais vous les posez
d'abord c'est peut-être un des éléments
les plus importants pour comprendre
pourquoi le temps ne s'impliquent pas
davantage quel est le risque poutine
l'utilisent l'arme nucléaire sachant que
les membres de l'otan répliquerait avec
force en russie demande claude bougies
oui c'est très bonne question puis c'est
la question qu'on veut pas se poser à
voix haute parce que les terrorisant on
peut se le dire on pensait jamais avoir
à se poser ces questions-là en 2022 la
menace nucléaire est en train de dicter
votre cas depuis le début la réponse de
l'auteur ce que le temps fait ou ne fait
pas pour aider l'ukraine c'est dicté par
sept par le fait que la russie est une
puissance nucléaire et pas n'importe
laquelle ou alors elles partagent la
moitié des des têtes nucléaires avec les
états unis la pierre angulaire des
relations américaines et russes depuis
la fin de la guerre froide est dictée
par le risque ou la peur d'une collision
militaire parce qu on sait qu une prison
militaire entre ces deux pays là pour
être très rapidement dégénéré en guerre
nucléaire donc il l'a brandi monsieur
poutine et il l'a brandi pas seulement
une fois ces porte parole parce qu'il
faut juste poutine qui parle il envoie
ses porte parole dans différentes
émissions moi je regarde encore beaucoup
la télévision d'état les messages qui
sont envoyées c'est c'est que l'âme
nucléaire même si on dit qu'on ne veut
pas l'utiliser peut-être utilisé s'il ya
une menace existentielle pour la russie
et c'est ce qu'on sait pas en ce moment
qu'est ce qui doit être considéré comme
une menace existentielle est ce que si
c'est une victoire de l'ukraine si c'est
une menace existentielle
oui le seuil oui les siècles et le temps
qui réunit aujourd'hui je pense que
louis blouin vous en faisait un résumé
depuis bruxelles parlait de ça comment
nous le tas qui est une force défensive
qui agissent ensemble on peut se
préparer à cette menace la en ukraine
mais compte nommant bruce très bien
diane martin de marne n'y at il pas un
moyen quelconque de m poutine horn et
d'état de nuire est-ce que
l'emprisonnement est envisageable
beaucoup de gens nous ont écrit pour
marc d est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas un
commando qui pourra les lacets cinéma
moritz est possible c'est possible dans
n'importe quelle poche à la dictature
mais auto création tout cas la cause est
une personne qui dirige ces treize
pâques le régime en russie il dirigea en
colonne savez à la verticale comme on
dit là bas beaucoup de gens autour de
lui a pas de successeur désigné donc
même s'il ya des gens qui pensent que
éliminé vladimir poutine serait une
solution pour finir en finir avec cette
guerre c'est c'est peut-être se tromper
parce que ça pourrait dégénérer en
guerre civile les le pouvoir pourrait
tomber entre les mains de quelqu'un
d'encore plus instable si il est
instable lui on ne sait pas mais
chez la population et je parle beaucoup
à des gens il n'y a pas de je ne vois
pas en tout cas pour l'instant de risque
de révolution et on dit que les
sanctions une fois qu'elles seront
appliquées une fois qu'elles feront mal
à la population celle aucun risque à les
gens aux fins les gens sortent dans la
rue mais pour l'instant au sein de sa
garde rapprochée
est ce qui pourrait avoir un scoop c'est
tellement pas qu'on sait maroc même
quand les gens démissionnent autour de
lui c'est difficile de le confirmer est
ce que ça pourrait être encore plus
instable lui l'état pôle up se lit
membres d'éventuelles négociations à
voir ça c'est intéressant dans
l'argumentaire le plaidoyer de poutine
il dit je vais chasser les nazis et
françois duranteau vous demande demande
y at il oui ou non une milice nous
n'osions il ya une milliers c'est un
régiment très connu qui s'appelle le
régiment d'azov
il faut retourner dans l'histoire il
faut prendre le temps pour expliquer qui
est ce régiment quand après la prise de
la crimée il ya eu une urgence des
séparatistes pro russes dans lougansk de
donetsk et vous là où la guerre commence
et l'armée ukrainienne n'étant pas ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
parce que là elle a été entraînée un peu
des années par les canadiens par les
américains par les européens faisait
appel à des milices volontaires parmi
elles le régiment d'azov
3ème droite combien exact le fondateur
très certainement combien de membres qui
ont rejoint les rangs de ce régiment le
sont exactement c'est très difficile à
dire beaucoup de d'encre a coulé ou
jamais oui c'est une c'est un régiment
qui à l'origine a des origines d'extrême
droite et qui a été intégrée
officiellement à l'armée ukrainienne
c'est le prétexte que se donne de la
lumière poutine très concrets pour
convaincre sa population qui a un régime
nazi en tout cas qui ont un
environnement en ukraine où on peut où
il ya de la place pour ce genre de
mouvement et comme dans toute propagande
mensonge ou ça parle d'un fond de vérité
c'est un bel exemple vous savez ce qui
est incroyable je parlais avec une amie
à moscou aujourd'hui voire empêcher
qu'elle est déprimé et ce qu'elle disait
ce qui est le plus déprimant c'est les
discussions que j'ai avec des gens que
je pensais bien informés qu'ils nous
disent qu'ils commencent à croire que
l'ukraine est en train de développer des
armes chimiques avec les américains ça
c'est le discours officiel du kremlin
c'est ce qu'on entend la télévision
d'état il force la propagande mais
extrait très bien
intéressant cette question du gérant
croteau ce que le fait les ukrainiens
d'abord connu le régime soviétique et
ensuite la démocratie explique pourquoi
ils sont prêts à mourir plutôt que se
retrouver à nouveau sous le joug du
russe ils sont prêts à mourir pour leur
pays et pour la liberté mais je sais pas
si c'est parce qu'ils avaient connu
l'union soviétique et a pris un peu de
liberté
j'ai toujours un malaise avec des
questions comme ça parce que la liberté
n'est pas un concept qui est importé de
l'ouest où d'ailleurs on est libre et on
se bat pour le garder il ya eu des d'une
histoire particulière en russie et avec
l'union soviétique mais très
certainement c'est un peuple qui se
soulève ya eu plusieurs tentatives de
révolution jusqu'à la révolution du
maiden où ils ont réussi à chasser un
gouvernement pro russe parce qu'ils ont
choisi l'ouest dans ce cas là mais
l'ouest pas pour nécessairement la
liberté l'ouest pour l'ouverture
économique
pour les opportunités donc mais aussi un
peu démocratique absolument parce qu'il
ya une autocratie chez le voisin russe
sauf que ce qui est intéressant c'est
que les ukrainiens en ce moment il se
bat pour quelque chose de très concret
et les gens disent tout le temps mais
pourquoi les russes sont pas dans la rue
en train de se battre ils se battent
pour leur vie en ce moment et les russes
et c'est quelqu'un c'est quelqu'un de
russes qui s'est exilé qui madison où on
se bat comme comme quelque chose de trop
gros et trop abstrait
et la réaction serait probablement
différente si le danger était imminent
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont tenu pour
acquis qu'ils pouvaient continuer
l'artiste vit en russie dans leur
confort sans conséquence il réalise que
c'est paul qu
à la demande c'est serge martin advenant
une participation de l'otan en ukraine
ce qui n'est pas le cas mais advenant
quels pays pourraient s'allier la russie
dans ce qui deviendrait finalement
guerre mondiale il ya plein de petites
alliés commença par le bélarus je pense
qu'on peut le pas en excès le belarus
mais c'est tout comme la chaîne lâche au
regard des lâches et c'est pas anodin de
reculer dans les années dans les
dernières années alors que la chine
s'isoler des états unis et la russie
aussi ces deux pays se sont se sont
réconciliés on peut le dire comme ça
jusqu'à a mené des exercices militaires
conjoints et on fait des grands
spectacles chaque année des fois c'est à
vladivostok des fois c'est en chine où
on affiche fièrement cette alliance
militaire qui est pas soudée mais quitte
en devenir donc faut surveiller et la
chesnaie dans un drôle de position en ce
moment elle ne peut pas imposer de
sanction
fournir des armes éventuellement va
falloir surveiller au cours des
prochaines semaines j semaine parce que
poutine je vous laisse là dessus et
justement vous me disiez salles le 9 mai
en russie mais tout arrête c'est jour de
la victoire de la grande guerre contre
les nazis c'est une journée sacrée les
enfants sont en costume militaire il ya
des cérémonies partout tout le monde
arrête de respirer poutine aurait dit à
ses généraux et à son armée qu'il veut
une victoire pour le 9 mai demeure
altérer ce qu'on veut se reparler d'ici
là mais c'est très intéressant merci au
revoir